you're here for the small nations we
talked United Kingdom we talk France we
talked China but there are small nations
worried about the flow of money of the
people that are in America for example
who want to send money to Samoa send
money to Liberia send money to Caribbean
why is this important for you first of
all it's important for them and it's not
a massive issue at the moment but it's
important for us because it could become
a massive issue because if we have more
banks withdrawing activities and what
they call correspondent bank you leave
those territories open to competition
probably not to third parties activities
to funny way of channeling money around
it's a risk for the entire community and
what's more important is that each and
every territory you talking about
Caribbean islands you talk about Pacific
Islands but you also talking about
Mexico you also talking about the
Philippines you also talking about
Colombia which are under the threat of
seeing some of those banks withdrawing
activity and withdrawing all together
from those territories and that is just
not conducive to activity to growth to
jobs and to legitimate business the
modern tension of this is global banking
with all the regulation and money
laundering worried about who the
customers customer is they don't know
where the money is going and they're
worried about civil and criminal
activity if they pursue this how are you
gonna help relieve the tension between
global banking and this idea of money
laundering you know in that case it
takes three to tango if I may say you
have the countries at risk which have to
up their game in order to make to make
sure that they comply with anti money
laundering regulations with
counter-financing tourism measures
that's one group right then you have the
regulator's who legitimately so require
that there be compliance with the rule
and then you have the third category
which is the financial sector the
banking industry which says why should I
take risks when I'm not too sure about
you know the business that is being
conducted in those countries what we are
advocating is that these three actually
get together even under our auspices if
needed in order to understand the
concerns of each of the three and each
of the three has to do something the
countries have to improve the compliance
they have to make sure that anti money
laundering
rules are complied with they have to
make sure that tax transparency is a
driver they have to make sure that
financing of tourism is off then the
regulators have to encourage to explain
to clarify their rules so that there is
no suspicion as to what is really their
purpose and the banks themselves have to
conduct their cost-benefit analysis but
also be mindful of not leaving
territories opened to what I would call
the weak link somebody who comes in and
says I'm going to the financial business
on the side all of these issues though
could be folded over to one nation and
that is Turkey you and I did not know on
Thursday that we would be speaking of
Turkey today and yet we are you asked
within your speech at the New York Fed
today how can the IMF help turkey is
turned upside down
how can your institution help mr. air21
and Turkey improve from the horrific
events we saw a Friday well with with
really our thoughts to those who have
lost their life in the last few days and
I would include more than turkey in my
thoughts at the moment but if we
concentrate on Turkey what I observe is
that as after what happened over the
weekend the central bank the financial
authorities have taken very immediate
and very concerted measures to avoid an
economic and financial massive
disruption that we could have had you
know over the weekend all of us were on
alert monitoring the situation and
wondering whether they would take the
right measures I think that the Turkish
authorities central bank finance
ministers Treasury operations have all
reacted very strongly very a
in a concerted way in order to make sure
that they'd be there would be liquidity
available that the banks could function
and markets reaction was actually
relatively moderate I mean it markets
went down and then up a little bit so
it's down a you know by about three
percent if I recall the lira which is
the currency of Turkey went down as well
a little bit but not by much and in the
main there was an orderly functioning of
the markets after something that was
massively disorderly of course April of
2013 you travel to New York at the
Economic Club of New York you gave a
most important speech and you talked
about the different speeds of Nations
you talked about America is a two-speed
nation and the third speed nation the
ones most struggling were Europe and
Japan you were right it's gotten worse
within a broad pan-european perspective
how do you judge the immediacy of
actions that need to be taken across a
wide set of issues you know if anything
in Europe the decision made by the
British people to exist the European
Union has accelerated in our view the
need to consolidate the European Union
to give a strong message to the European
people about the benefit that Europe can
actually deliver for them concentrating
on the positive focusing on key issues
for the people of Europe in is in our
view an immediate and urgent response
that needs to bring together monetary
policy fiscal space wherever it is
available and those reforms that will
actually deliver value for people it's
it's all very well to say or we need
consolidation here and we need reforms
there what reforms what benefits what
what value will it bring to the European
people so that they understand that
there is value in being together
David folkert slander out Deutsche Bank
is pushing aggressively for a
substantial bailout program of the
Italian banks Bloomberg News had an
article today on the Bundesbank
beginning to waver on how they would
respond to the Italian banks when you
talk to your best people at the IMF what
is their prescription to help Italy not
be Greece
I would not compare the two countries
for a long way totally different
economies and and totally different
fundamentals our sense at the moment is
that the Italian authorities are really
not only aware of the issues that they
have to deal with but they have an
understanding of what devices what
structure what bad bank so to speak can
be used we also believe that these
solutions can be operated within the
European framework as it exists today
there is a framework that is intended to
organize proper bail-in in order not to
impose upon taxpayer in to restore
financial stability there is a way to
deal with the Italian bank situations
the high level of non-performing loans
in some of them in particular and to
comply with the European regulations
which provide for exceptional
circumstances if need be so we are
certainly not advocating a massive
revamp of the regulations but complying
with the rules respecting the state aid
as well being you know focus on the real
issues should help them to get it's an
interesting thing because you and other
institutional leaders are learning as
you go like anyone else so we have bail
out you mentioned bail in some would be
rude enough to call it a cram down where
in the case of Italy they force the
losses on to the public on to the voters
in a time of populist emotion and
activity what is the prescription to
avoid that pain within Italy or for that
matter Portugal transparency is is in
our view necessary focus on the
institutions that need either support or
a way of resolving the issues they're
facing non-performing loans is one
certainly and complying with a set of
rules that have just recently been
adopted to the extent as we believe that
those rules provide the space to resolve
the issues
there is a dialogue ongoing between the
European authorities and the Italian
authorities Italian authorities are spot
on in identifying the problems they seem
to be very keen to resolve it the
European authorities want the rules to
be complied with we believe that there
is a space in order to address the issue
in compliance with the rules with
eventually the space and the flexibility
that is needed Madame Lagarde just
because of time I need to move on have
you spoken yet to Prime Minister May
no but I've spoken already to the year
that the new chancellor of the exchequer
Philip Hammond what an exceptional time
for the United Kingdom the last country
I would think the International Monetary
Fund would have to deliver wisdom to it
would be the United Kingdom but after
the success of the brexit referendum
what is the council what is the path you
can take to assist Prime Minister May to
move the United Kingdom forward in their
negotiations with Brussels in Europe
well first of all there has been
significant progress in the the
macroeconomic situation of Great Britain
over the last five years we've seen it
clearly move from a 10 percent fiscal
deficit to more than half that now my
recommendation would be to really reduce
the level of uncertainty identify
clearly what the goals are identify the
timeline and as Philip Hammond said
understand that it will take time but it
will require understanding on both sides
in order to eliminate the trade
uncertainty the regulatory uncertainty
the passport uncertainty when there's a
whole range of issues which have which
need to be addressed which have brought
the European countries together and from
which clearly the United Kingdom as in
as indicated and in its intention to
withdraw so clarity of intent rapidity
of execution identification of both the
goal and the timelines would be very
helpful are you pleased with what you've
seen out of European leaders so far you
go
in a few days to Chengdu and the g20
meetings we are focused on the United
Kingdom are you pleased with the
messaging from Chancellor Merkel mr.
younger and others within Europe you
know for the moment they have not and
deliberately so decided to lay out the
terms and the space and the maneuvering
that they all want to offer or expect
from their partner and I understand that
because there has to be certainty about
the timeline the two years which will be
triggered by this article 50 which has
not yet been invoked will open a limited
period of time and I can see why they
wouldn't want to you know put their
cards on the table yet but if on the
other side the United Kingdom moves in
the direction of what I call you know
clarity of purpose transparency
indication of time line then certainly
the Europeans should respond my hope my
real hope as a European myself is that
the European leaders will find the
strength and the determination to
actually bring about some of those
structural reforms changes that will
deliver value to the Europeans that will
demonstrate that it is worth being
together and it's it's the future it is
the future our future may be in
Cleveland with a Republican convention
or in Philadelphia with a Democrat
convention you have been exceptionally
overt about your comments on this
presidential campaign what do you fear
in the comments from mr. Trump about the
International economy and our political
economics I fear from any candidate
actually anywhere in the world but it's
more pressing now but I feel from any
candidate anywhere in the world this
withdrawal behind borders this focus on
domestic market issues exclusively this
turning their back to globalization and
global issues because problems are often
global natures because we are in this
together
disease climate change terrorism threats
have no barriers have no borders
so to assume that we can do away with
international trade we can do away with
globalization I think is an illusion in
the collective memory of World War two
I've mentioned Konrad Adenauer a number
of times in comments over the last
number of weeks and I think of Charles
to call on the courage he had and trying
to move the debate forward with Jean
Monnet the critical question then is
within Henry Kissinger's Westphalian
system of Nations is the Washington
Consensus dead you know future will tell
but it's clear that they are large
powers large economies and and powerful
authorities that need to have a seat at
the table and a say in that global game
in which we all are and I think from an
IMF perspective the fact that for
instance in large emerging market
economies like China like Brazil like
India have a legitimate space around the
circle of nations interested in the
well-being of humanity is only one but
certainly one needed response to the
global challenges that we are facing so
it cannot be a zero-sum game it cannot
be a One Nation strategy and an
consensus it has to be a much broader
table in the time that we've got left -
lugia Blanchard who worked for you for
many years and provided great assistance
to the IMF stunned me the other day by
calling helicopter money a scam are we
exhausted by our creative policies
you've been you've been the adult in the
room and saying many of these strategies
won't work I believe professor Blanchard
agrees with you when you hear of
helicopter money how do you react you
turn to Maurice Obstfeld and say please
discuss what you do well Maurice is
Maurice officer this is a fantastic
counsellor so I would turn to him
but I think that the scam notion which
is a bit provocative as Olevia can be on
occasions is another way to say this is
really fiscal stimulus to the extra
involving different agents but
essentially it's a fiscal device and at
this point in time I think he would
agree with us that some countries have
some fiscal space not many and what the
others should do that don't have fiscal
space is actually recalibrate and
redesigned their fiscal policies to make
it more growth friendly rather than less
growth friendly because what we need is
inclusive sustainable growth so that
people can actually find a meaning get a
job and have a decent income